allora ecco ma si sposta sta merda è un
tronco dio santo come fa a spostarsi un
tronco quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo nuovi dio sono fa vj si sta
alzando il vento quindi e va bene devo
muovere il culo se non fa vj e siamo in
un posto bello vi spiego un attimo come
che cosa diavolo ci sto facendo qui
allora siamo a venezia e sono stato
invitato da sky per parlare ai capi
grossi di tutte le tv del mondo che si
riuniscono tipo una volta l'anno in una
specie di resort
credo sia un resort siccome non ci sono
arrivato volando vi faccio vedere come
ci sono arrivato qui perché ovviamente
ho bloccato tutto o un bajari bonjour
haga suoli belli siamo qua c'è l'acqua
non seriamente siamo a venezia e siamo
per salina in barca anche lui che mi
sorride nel mentre che sto facendo
bella prova per salire in barca in this
moment
salve a non salire grazie si può andare
qui sotto che figo se non prive di
quelli dei dj ma vabbè bellissima
strappatevi sopportato le cuffie da
gaming poi veramente signore mangia
banana bene tutti ragazzi
lui era triste cosa va detta addio
ma perchè vi chiediamo a sbattere egli
sa quanto sia per stati passi ma fa un
metro in più eravamo morti e orali che
c'è una porta che dà verso il canale
direttamente uno si sbaglia ad aprire
apre per caso e bambini ci siamo
arrivati ragazzi sull'isola privata di
sto cazzo se va bene tutto questo è
tutto questo è un isola
poi ce lo ha portato un trattore su
un'isola è cresciuto veramente la cosa
che mi fa impazzire di più è che questa
è una cazzo di isola c'è nel senso do
posto muro tipo l'attacco di giganti non
c'è il cazzo c'è il mare è una cosa
stupisce un cancello chiuso con
l'antifurto ma che cazzo mettono
l'antifurto che c'è il mare o lo zerbino
se non riesco non riesco a concepire la
roba che c'è una cazzo di coso qua e poi
c'è il mare il coso e il mare il coso e
il mare il coso che cazzo si fanno ad un
cancello cosa deve entrare una macchina
quasi subito c'è il mare subito dopo wow
purtroppo fino ai ragazzi come mio
solito siamo arrivati nell'otello hanno
potuto riprendere nella hall perché ci
stava gente mi vergognavo questa la mia
stanza questo è il mio numero così
venite a trovare tutti quanti stanotte
facciamole megaparty comunque sia bello
premesso il cesso già acceso e va bene
quanto bello ci sta c'è c'è una vista
così veramente le pastiglie per il mal
di mare e cos'è sta roba
cos'è mai mio prestito fa vj così un
regalo di chi in regalo che si sciatto
chi me l'ha fatto l'hotel fino all'hotel
non se quanto gliene frega l'hotel di te
cos'è sarò mi hanno fatto una sacca
posti topham j
che tipo wheaton mi fa una pippa vita
che va aprile è talmente grande che ci
stai dentro anche the brother dentro
[Risate]
aspetto e seicos east è così allora fai
un passo avanti un passo avanti
[Musica]
va bene mica sono appena arrivato chieda
ris hilton non ho capito di miglior
cielo volavano padri figli di [ __ ]
io sono più bello che si lavora pure
bravo bene come hai fatto a chiamarmi
che ti chiamo anche di notte grazie
brutto stronzo ci vediamo dopo bella
ragazzi il televisore è bellissimo è la
ost uni virgola lorenzo proprio ingegno
stay with art
grazie per il mio letto è sempre libero
per te a parte per il mio telefono
perché lui mi si adagia sempre sul letto
perché vuole il sesso guarda paris non
avevo proprio dubbi che la tua barca
fosse quella c'è veramente non avevo un
cazzo di dubbio c'è ma dai rega comunque
ragazzi stavo per andare a farmi la
vasca da bagno perché c'è una vasca da
bagno
nell'hotel non so manco io a casa e si
sono i ragazzi che è che cazzo che ci
crediate un ma veramente ve lo giuro
la presa del bagno non funziona dove
devo asciugarmi capelli così con le
ascelle
io veramente sto usando la fotocamera
per asciugare i capelli perché non
andava al cono in bagno ma dio come
cazzo si fa a non far funzionare la
presa del bagno paris hilton destò
grande
[Musica]
e cazzo ma va da sé stesso rumore
ragazzi di campanelline che che fanno di
nein nein nein
ecco tutta questa bella gente che sono
tutti quelli il boss di televisioni
quando c'è la conferenza che appunto
tutti fanno sto meeting che gli ho già
fatto sono tutti lì ad ascoltare poi
fanno un break ogni tanto vengono poi in
giardino quando li devono richiamare
dentro non è che li chiamano e dicono a
cui arredi donò fanno suonare ai
campanelli né di sto caxxo non siccome
le mucche o appena caricato un video su
instagram non si vede un cazzo va bene
la bella la connessione che c'è
sull'isola utile primo mi piace grazie
grazie kevin gramma sei un cane che
stiamo aspettando che esca sa in un caos
sarebbe colui che ha scoperto il bund
era quindi più che scoperto e lui li ha
assemblati e colui che ha assemblato a
bande rai5 stessa sigla un nuovo boy
band composta da bere
ok ok olio volti espressioni del suo ok
ragazzi c'è una serata di gala posso
anche norme perché non dovrei registrare
mai nella vita però lo faccio lo stesso
perché lì
non ci credo mai dai [ __ ]
veramente che sfiga perfetto ragazzi
siamo in piazza san favi jc anche questa
cattedrale grossa questo è più di pie è
veramente fighissimo ragazzi e quel che
mancasse
in difesa magari anche ciao bella vaga
io non sono vera nei bandi 20 ferie a di
principe hanno sbagliato da grave e
pulita
arrivederci che bello questo negozio di
giochi le spade spider man ma che cazzo
la lega
caracas
quindi ragazzi questo è stato il mio
tripla venezia è stato troppo figo il
fatto è che non avevo mai visto venezia
in vita mia davvero è stata la prima
volta in vita mia venezia veramente io
non credevo che fosse così bella me
l'aspettavo bella ma non così tanto
giuro comunque sia ragazzi c'è un altro
argomento del quale vi vorrei parlare
che vedete un blog infinito questo
sabato sta per uscire il 29 giugno
uscirà il film di ratchet e clank dal 29
al 3 luglio poi non lo danno più perché
un film evento e nel film di ratchet e
clank ci sono io che ho doppiato un
personaggio che anche se a poche battute
è un figo perché lo doppiato yo bene vi
avevo già fatto vedere la scena del
doppiaggio nell'altro blog però me ne
hanno date altre quindi posso farvene
vedere altre vi lascio questo aspetto e
gate posso farti pona reactions come io
vi giuro che non l'ho ancora vista
perché ok o d'aspetto deciso adesso
faccio una reaction reaction in live
certo che questa guerra il backstage
doppio zed che un robottino
simpaticissimo ea degli sbalzi d'umore
incredibili che
il che mi rappresenta un sacco questo
definitivamente vi rappresenta un sacco
perché sono e sono proprio io siamo a
scambiarci posti ora mi fa morire dal
ridere un paio di queste mi sono
bloccati un doppiaggio perché mi veniva
da ridere d'ascoltare lava figlio che
non avete idea se non ha nemmeno la mia
e mail and space senza 72 tech data
sono veramente contento di aver scelto
lui soltanto il panda attuale per il
resto noi e questa era una delle mie
scene preferite lega è bellissima queste
belle è una delle mie preferite in
assoluto cioè veramente come la rivedere
giuro quando hai visto zitto quando ho
visto quella originale
stavo cadendo veramente per terra da
ridere e genia il film in sé geniale poi
se mi sono anch'io quindi eccellente
lettera di raccomandazione mio dio
bellissimo
l'aria
io ho detto perché qua era un macello
la mail è veramente space gangsta 72 at
the punto com
ad oggi questa rosa parte di un bensì
mare prima che cominciate a farmi delle
domande è importante che sappiate che io
sono fedele al mio datore di lavoro
ed è così che ho scoperto di essere
intollerante al lattosio sebbene credo
che il pappagallino sarebbe morto
comunque perché quindi non lo farà
cadere il treno mi vengo questo doveva
essere un lavoro temporaneo mentre
avviavo la mia carriera di cantante che
poi la mia carriera di cantante non è il
massimo della vita è meglio io non abbia
avviato la mia carriera di cantante sono
più contento così guarda dunque si
ragazzi io volevo veramente spendere due
parole per la gentilezza e l'incredibile
professionalità di quest'uomo che state
vedendo le sto abbracciando si chiama
massimiliano alto ma è dal nome magari
non lo conosce nessuno mai tipo la voce
di aladino per farvi un esempio così è
vanto gesticolato in società è stato
veramente se non fosse stato per lui non
sarei riuscito a doppiare nemmeno mezza
ma neanche mezza scena vale il
doppiatore e è difficile cioè un lavoro
e io non sono doppiatori quindi
veramente un casino anche se ho fatto 10
battute che sono veramente poche
quindi non va ad intaccare niente non
sarebbero mai venute così se non fosse
stato per lui che ha fatto veramente un
lavoro della madonna è veramente un
fenomeno e dedicarli questi secondi per
ringraziarlo veramente di cuore me lo
sposerei se non fossi uomo e se non
fosse probabilmente già sposato
vabbè che sia ragazzi io il film
personalmente l'ho già visto perché mi
hanno già fatto vedere in anteprima
spero veramente che vi piace e ci
abbiamo messo la mente tutto l'impegno
possibile ricorda ragazzi che nei cinema
soltanto dal 29 giugno al 3 luglio
quindi fatemi sapere se andate a vederlo
ovviamente fatevi delle foto su mandelli
basta parlare mettetele su instagram
così vedo quanti voi sono andati a
vedere il film ovviamente tagliate mi
sono un cazzo faccia vedere cosa sai che
se vi è piaciuto l'argomento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
noi video totana descrizione se dovessi
di scrittori ci dividiamo posto
mi si è staccato il pezzo dietro del
telecomando spero non succeda recente
nel film che potrebbe essere grave
preparatevi per un'avventura spaziale
bella ragazzi